I am a holistic psychiatrist but I  rarely prescribe psychiatric medications  I want you to understand that  psychiatric medications do not treat any  underlying disorder at best they only  mask symptoms which were messages that  your body actually needed you to hear  and what's worse they are also highly  addictive and if you ever try to stop  taking them you will find it extremely  challenging if not impossible that  sounds like crazy everything she's  saying is exactly spot on and because 20  percent of America is on psych meds  you're going to get a ton of people  they're like oh no they're improving my  life they're definitely improving my  life which is literally what I said how  I acted before I tried to stop taking  them and then was like oh I knew  painkillers were addictive but sorry the  antidepressants I've been on since I was  12 are causing physical dependence that  mimic symptoms of depression that's what  the withdrawal is like just wreaks havoc  on your body